well so much for retirement for antonio
brown and we knew at the time that he
that he basically gave in to the
frustration a couple of weeks ago
because the nfl had yet to let him know
what
his status was that it really wasn't a
permanent retirement he would
continue to wait for word from the nfl
as to what his status is the word came
friday afternoon eight-game suspension
for antonio brown for violating the
nfl's personal conduct policy that's the
headline
the the text though of the story
is more important than the headline
because it doesn't end
all nfl business as it relates to
antonio brown's potential violations of
the personal conduct policy he had three
things that the nfl was investigating
this eight-game suspension applies to
two of them
what is still left is the thing that got
this all started chris september of last
year the
lawsuit filed against antonio brown for
sexual assault and rape
that hasn't been resolved yet the nfl
i'm told
has conducted an investigation the nfl
has not yet been able to come to a
conclusion
the nfl will potentially take action
based upon further evidence and i think
what the nfl's doing here is protecting
itself against
a verdict in the civil case that antonio
brown did what he's accused of doing
right and if the nfl has previously
exonerated him
then they look foolish because they get
superseded
by a verdict that says hey nfl you got
it wrong
you made an excuse for a guy that a
civil court in florida
decided did commit sexual assault and
rape so i think that is their out
that is their we we reserve the right to
change our minds later which i get it
do you not get that or what i mean i no
i don't i get it but i don't like it
right because
you put an apparatus in place to make
these decisions
nfl you make a decision regardless of
what happens in court
you know they suspended ezekiel at six
games
and there was no criminal proceeding and
there was never even a civil proceeding
right there was no lawsuit filed against
him
sometimes you've and if you're gonna set
up this
in-house justice system you can't just
punt
and say well we don't really know
and we know that there's another
mechanism out there that may
make us look bad because they may
disagree with us so we better not do
anything no make a decision and if the
evidence is inconclusive
then then then close the case we've
talked to the
alleged victim we've talked to him we've
pursued other evidence
and we are at a point where we cannot
conclude that he violated the policy
well good then he didn't violate the
policy
and end this well these things have to
come to an end at some point you just
can't sit back and say
we'll revisit this if and when this
civil lawsuit gets resolved with a
verdict against antonio brown i don't
like that
it's one of the many things i don't like
about the personal conduct policy yeah
they need to do the investigation
make a decision and move on if you're
gonna have a justice system you gotta
dispense
justice just as delayed as they say in
the legal system is justice denial well
what's taking the civil case so long do
we really know that
they have to always take they always
they always take forever in september
they always take forever well listen
they always do you know like
i i i mean this it's a tough one i mean
you're right
it's not right that he has to sit there
and wait all this time and do all that
but i also think with a guy like antonio
brown with some of the issues he's had
to deal with
that they got to take their time and be
careful here because like
to what you're saying all right like
let's just say the simple
guns to civil or let's say the nfl
suspends them two extra games right
for this thing because they oh we don't
know we didn't you know find enough
evidence of wrongdoing but yeah you put
yourself in a bad situation
and conduct detrimental the shield
whatever blah blah blah
so we're gonna spend you you know
suspend you two games
okay but you know then you have like the
civil the civil lawsuit and maybe
something
comes out that we didn't know about or
more evidence of it
nfl should have found out about that but
that's the thing if you're going to put
a system in place to investigate you got
to find this stuff you're right then
they need to take the
system out because it's it's it's stupid
because they're going to they're burning
themselves ultimately they've put
themselves in a very tough spot
so yes i and so to with you there i
agree like
get get it get done with it be be over
with it because you're right right now
they have they placed a system to where
yeah guys life is on hold certainly
now you know has he acted appropriately
do i feel horrible for a guy that his
life's been put on hold
not necessarily i mean he's had a few
strikes here we know that
and i think that's got to lead them to
being a little bit more careful than
usual as well
so i don't know ultimately what do you
think this does to antonio brown
like i still don't think any team's
going to sign them until we hear about
this last piece of the puzzle right i
mean i don't think anything no no
no no no i think the message is i think
the message i think that
that when i when i look at what they
said
and i factor in what i know i think the
message
is it's unlikely that anything more is
going to come
out of this incident this civil suit in
florida especially if he
if he does what he should have done
before it was ever filed which is settle
the thing
you can settle the thing with an
agreement that
that the alleged victim will not
cooperate with anyone unless she's
subject to a subpoena she won't talk
about it she won't say anything
cases get settled with those terms in
them all the time
and she's already talked to the nfl
she's not going to say anything more to
the nfl and if they don't have enough
evidence based upon what she's already
said
they'll have enough evidence to do
anything but see the problem is this
entire thing
is born of a misguided pr
concern that the nfl has to police guys
lives
away from work in the months that the
season isn't even happening
and the more they chase that pr angle
the more you get
unfair results and the fact that yeah
and you touched on this antonio brown's
an unsympathetic figure
so it's harder to muster the will to
stand up and pound on the table
for fairness and justice for antonio
brown because you're like well you know
he kind of gets what he deserves i mean
you've got that nagging sense
that that that this is all in a weird
sort of way
justified but at the same time this
exposes the flaws the very deep and
profound flaws in the personal conduct
policy
he's already served chris a 14-game
unpaid suspension yeah because teams
last year
right believed that if they signed him
with this
sexual assault and rape lawsuit pending
and the investigation the nfl not
resolved
he'd be put on the commissioner
exemplars and they'd be paying him not
to play
well now the end result of what happened
friday is hey once he serves his
eight-week suspension or eight game
suspension it's eight weeks if he's not
on a team it's eight games if he is on a
team
he's good to go that's the message they
don't have to i i think the last thing
that's going to happen is
yeah he's going to serve his eight-game
suspension and then somebody signs him
and the airfield goes hey sorry he's on
the commissioner exemplist until we
figure out this other thing that's
still pending right that that game is
over
he's going to serve eight games and he's
going to be ready to go the question is
who's going to give him a job either
before then
or after the eighth week of the season
well there's going to be some teams that
are going to be interested
certainly but you know that that is
going to have to get figured out and i
guess where i go here mike is like
so what is the nfl what's the next step
though the nfl just got to like
wait for these cases to get resolved in
court at some point if they don't one
case
yeah one case that's it one case so the
case that was filed last september
alleging that he sexually assaulted and
raped a former trainer the thing that
that first put this mess on his docket
and put him in a position where he was
the subject of investigation that's
still there
and i think that when you read between
the lines and i assume that teams will
be talking to the league office see when
teams talk to the league office during
the season
the message they got was i believe i
don't know this but i think
circumstances bear this out
the message they got was you know if you
sign him right we're probably
going to put him on the commissioner i
think the message now
is the eight games pays his debt
to the nfl and this other thing
is just kind of gonna fizzle out unless
there's a verdict against him unless
there's some dramatic courtroom
testimony
that creates a pr urgency to take
further action again
p it's not driven by any sense of
justice it's driven by protecting the
shield
and that's what makes it wholly unsuited
in the first place and they should tear
it down
burn it down roll it up into a ball and
throw it away because there is nothing
about it that speaks of fairness and
justice for
the players it's when you try to get
into the business
of investigating it and doing it
yourself it's one thing to say
player pleaded guilty to a felony
we're going to impose punishment and
that's that's one of the reasons why he
suspended eight games he pleaded no
contest to felony charges
arising from the incident that he had
with a driver of a moving truck earlier
this year right you get suspended that's
the way it used to be
that all changed with ray rice greg
hardy
adrian peterson where they felt like
they had to do something more
than sit back and wait for what the
justice system does because if you
remember the ray rice thing from six
years ago
he he got he got a diversion program or
probation or something
that didn't really match what he should
have gotten and that's when the nfl felt
like well we need to make our own
decisions
we can't trust the justice system
anymore in a weird sort of way they've
come full circle
they have and now they're they're back
to trusting
the justice system for the final word on
this antonio brown case
yeah well i mean the other thing that
jumped out to me mike is the fact that
antonio brown didn't appeal the
suspension either which would make me
believe that
he thinks maybe this civil suit and all
that
could fizzle out as well like hey all
right that's good all right i'll pay my
you know my debt to society hash you
know whatever the nfl
and just you know take the eight games
and see where it goes from here
you know so maybe he's got a feel for
that as well and we'll see where it goes
but
either way if if the nfl
gives off the the sense of yes teams are
calling
and unlike last year where you said they
were going uh we'll probably put him on
the nfl you know the commissioner exempt
list
if they're getting the sense this year
that that's not gonna be the case
you're gonna have a handful of teams
call for antonio brown there's no doubt
about it
even though he hasn't played football in
a year or whatever else he still
is not far enough removed from his prime
or being one of the best receivers in
football to where i would think a
handful of teams
you know want his services coming up
next hour we're gonna have a draft of
the teams that we think
should sign antonio brown and i now
believe
assuming he can get through august
september october with no further
incidents and
some may say that that's that's not a
justified assumption
assuming he can stay out of trouble over
the next three
months i think he'll be back we'll draft
the teams that we think
should sign him hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports